IT COMES WITH HIM INFLATING HIS
RESUME ABOUT WHERE HE WENT TO
SCHOOL, WORKED, A NONPROFIT
HELPING PETS.
JASON CAROL HAS LOOKED.
>> Reporter: THROUGHOUT HIS
CAMPAIGN GEORGE SANTOS WOULD
REFER TO HIMSELF AS HALF JEWISH
OR A LATINO JEW.
TELLING HIS GRANDPARENTS' STORY
HOW HE SAYS THEY SURVIVED THE
HOLOCAUST AS UKRAINIAN JEWISH
REFUGEES, AND CONVERTING TO
CATHOLICISM.
HERE'S HOW HE EXPLAINED IT LAST
MONTH.
>> I'M PROUD OF MY GRANDPARENTS'
STORY.
MY GRANDFATHER FLEEING UKRAINE,
FLEEING STALIN'S PERSECUTION,
GOING TO BELGIUM, FINDING REFUGE
THERE, MARRYING MY GRANDMOTHER,
FLEEING HITLER AND GOING TO
BRAZIL.
THAT'S A STORY OF PERSEVERANCE.
>> Reporter: IT'S A STORY THAT
MAY NOT BE TRUE.
HIS MISREPRESENTATIONS OF HIS
FAMILY HISTORY FIRST REPORTED BY
THE JEWISH PUBLICATION THE
FORWARD.
RECORDS FROM THE HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM AND THE INTERNATIONAL
CENTER OF NAZI PERSECUTION WHICH
KEEPS RECORDS ON JEWISH REFUGEES
SHOW NO MENTION OF SANTOS'
GRANDPARENTS.
ONE GENEALOGY SEARCH SAID
THERE'S NO SIGN OF JEWISH AND/OR
UKRAINIAN HERITAGE AND NO
INDICATION OF NAME CHANGES ALONG
THE WAY.
>> I'M SO PROUD TO KEEP OUR
FAMILY GOING FORWARD SHOWING
THAT NOT ONLY DID WE SURVIVE BUT
I'M ABLE TO ADVOCATE AND FIGHT
FOR OTHER JEWISH PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: SANTOS HAS NOT
RESPONDED TO CNN REQUESTS TO
COMMENTS ABOUT HIS JEWISH
HISTORY.
PEOPLE ARE PERPLEXED THEY'RE
ASKING ME HOW COULD SOMEONE TELL
THIS SCALE OF LIES AND GET
ELECTED.
SANTOS' BIOGRAPHY HAS, AT TIMES,
CLAIMED HE EARNED DEGREES IN
FINANCE AND ECONOMICS.
CNN FOUND HE ALSO SAID, IN AT
LEAST TWO SEPARATE INTERVIEWS,
HE RECEIVED AN MBA FROM NYU.
>> TODAY I STAND VERY PROUD WITH
THE BACHELOR'S AND MASTERS
DEGREE ALL NEW YORK EDUCATED.
>> Reporter: A SPOKESMAN FOR NYU
TELLING CNN SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THE UNIVERSITY RECORDS DO NOT
REFLECT ANYONE WITH THAT NAME
HAVING ATTENDED NYU.
WHILE A SPOKESPERSON FOR BERUT
COLLEGE COULD NOT FIND ANYONE
WITH HIS NAME OR BIRTHDAY
ATTENDING THE SCHOOL.
HIS CAMPAIGN BIO MENTIONED
STINTS AT CIIGROUP AND GOLDMAN
SACHS.
NEITHER HAVE RECORDS OF HIS
EMPLOYMENT.
HE LISTED ON HIS 202 FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE A SALARY OF $750,000
AND CLAIMED HE MADE THE SAME
AMOUNT LAST YEAR, INCOME HE SAID
HE EARNED FROM THE DEVOLDER
ORGANIZATION WHICH HE SAID IS
HIS FAMILY FIRM.
A SEARCH SHOWS IT WAS REGISTERED
IN FLORIDA LAST YEAR.
THE STATE DEEMED IT INACTIVE FOR
FAILURE TO FILE REPORTS.
CNN FOUND SANTOS FILED THE
REPORT TUESDAY.
SANTOS' ATTORNEY SAID HE
REPRESENTS THE KIND OF PROGRESS
THAT THE LEFT IS SO THREATENED
BY, A GAY LATINO IMMIGRANT AND
REPUBLICAN WHO WON A BIDEN
DISTRICT IN OVERWHELMING
FASHION.
THE NASSAU COMMITTEE CHAIR
CALLED THE ISSUES SERIOUS ADDING
EVERY PERSON DESERVES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR HIS OR HER
NAME IN THE FACE OF ACCUSATIONS.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONGRESSMAN-ELECT'S RESPONSES TO
THE NEWS REPORT.
>> MY PARENTS CAME